okay so chainsaw man episode 3 is here
and in this video we're about to break
down the main things you need to know
during this third episode denji brutally
fights against the bat devil and today
we'll be explaining why power let that
happen and one of the major historical
differences between the world of
Chainsaw man and the real world before
we get into it though if you've been
enjoying these weekly reviews then I'd
really appreciate it if you hit that sub
button and as usual drop a like as well
as it does help out the channel alright
so at the end of episode 2 power
destroyed the Cucumber devil and like I
explained in that previous review she
was 100 not allowed to do that according
to Japanese law government devil Hunters
like power aren't allowed to Kill Devils
that the civilian devil Hunters are
already engaged with the way I see it
this rule is just a good way of
protecting the wages of the civilian
devil Hunters since they only get paid
based on the Devils that they capture
and kill and so by power killing the sea
cucumber in this way it potentially
means that this guy might not get paid
anyhow episode 3 then begins with makama
explaining to powwow why what she did
was against the rules but denji somehow
also managed just to get in trouble for
failing to control her when she ran away
following that there were two
interesting things we loved from this
whole scene the first being about
power's relationship with makima as we
saw last week power usually has an
outgoing personality and she views
herself as Superior to both humans and
other Devils but when it comes to makima
she instantly shuts up when she's told
to and was horrified when she thought
she might be in trouble this shows us
that unlike denji power is able to
acknowledge all of makama's red flags
and she knows their lives were on the
line if they mess up secondly in this
conversation she throws denji under the
bus by trying to frame him for what
happened and this was a subtle
indication of how she'd be willing to
betray him again later in the episode in
her own words she made it pretty clear
that she's always had this inherent
hatred for humans and so from the first
time they met Powell was always willing
to sacrifice him if it benefited her in
some way this brings us to the next
scene where she reveals that her true
motivation in life is to save her pet
cat meowy who was stolen from her by a
devil in the last episode it showed that
she had a fascination with cats and has
been because they're the only species
that she actually gets along with if we
flash back to when power first became a
fiend she survived by drinking the blood
of various animals but initially she
decided not to eat this cat because it
was too skinny instead what she wanted
was to let it grow bigger before she
drank his blood and in the process she
looked after meowy until it turned into
a nice pudgy Cat by the time that
transformation was complete though the
two of them had already grown attached
to each other and for the first time
powerhood lost her urge to kill
something however out of nowhere one
night meowy was kidnapped by the bat
devil who was injured from a previous
battle he had with devil Hunters having
lost his arm he wanted human blood to
regenerate himself but was too weak in
his current form to go out and find
someone that's why he kidnapped meowy as
a way to force Power to capture a human
for him but before she could complete
the task she was captured by makima as a
result meowy has been with the bat devil
this entire time and because she isn't
allowed to leave devil Hunter HQ by
herself she's not been able to do
anything about it during her
conversation with denji she's reminded
of her pet thanks to this random cat
that she picks up and she admits to him
that she'd do anything to get meowy back
although he initially had zero interest
in helping her he casually mentions that
he'd be willing to do anything to fondle
some melons which gives power an idea in
exchange for denji helping to save meowy
she offers him the chance to feel her
chest therefore allowing both of them to
fulfill their dreams of course this
whole proposal was fake since she was
planning to betray him but as usual
denji ignored the red flag from earlier
and decided to trust that she was just
being honest the possibility of grabbing
boobs is just something that he couldn't
pass up and so he was willing to look
past power's obvious untrustworthiness
if it gets him where he needs to be
following that the two of them Venture
off to confront the bat devil and this
moment was hilarious mainly because of
how demji was able to control himself by
staring at her melons remember at the
beginning of the episode we saw how
badly these two can argue when they
disagree about something but here when
power is annoying him he simply pauses
for a second looks at her chest and then
just lets it go without arguing back to
put this another way he's literally
harnessing his horniness to control his
other emotions which to be fair is the
most mature thing he's done in the
entire Series so far meanwhile back at
devil Hunter HQ makima has a meeting
with the higher ups and from this we
find out that the Soviet Union is still
a thing in this universe because
chainsaw man is set in an alternate
version of History it means that certain
major political events never happened
allowing for huge differences in the
timeline one of those differences is
that the Soviet Union never collapsed
and In This Moment someone mentions that
there are people inside the country who
are kind of eager to engage in a war
with the US the American Master is
referring to some unknown political
event happening in the United States
which for whatever reason has got the
Soviets super angry on top of that
they're also potentially using Devils
for military purposes which to be honest
I'm surprised that this is just a rumor
we all know that if Devils were real
then pretty much every country on Earth
would be fighting for control of the
strongest ones but here they're
surprisingly making it sound like using
Devil's war is something that doesn't
ordinarily happen as the meeting comes
to an end the higher-ups asked makima
about the progress of her experimental
Squad referring to special division 4
and she implies to them that power has a
lot of potential while denji is
interesting on the car ride home Aki
then gets salty about that comment since
his belief is that Genji is just a gross
idiot who doesn't deserve any kind of
Praise part of this soulsiness is caused
by jealousy which I talked about in my
previous video however there's also the
fact that at this point in time his
experience with Dengue has been pretty
much awful as far as Aki has seen Genji
is just an annoying roommate with no
convictions in life who believes he can
be friends with devils and can
apparently turn into a devil although as
of right now he's not even seen that
potential for himself makama then
replies by giving him a lesson in Devil
lore by explaining that every devil out
there is born with a name and the more
that name is feared the more powerful
the devil becomes the strength of the
devil is directly correlated to the
amount of people that fear the thing it
represents meaning that something like
the coffee devil would be weak whereas a
car devil would be stronger considering
that people die from car accidents
literally every day given that denji can
turn into the chainsaw devil his
potential makes him just in case but Aki
doesn't want to hear it as he sticks to
his belief that chainsaw man isn't fit
to be a double Hunter because he doesn't
have any real motivations or goals now
switching back to Power and denji after
getting off the bus the two of them then
arrive at the house where the bat devil
is hiding and as they walk up to it it
was kind of funny how she thought denji
was joking when he said that he didn't
want to chainsaw out like what this
shows is that even by the standards of
this world where there are devils
everywhere his powers are still so
ridiculous that even an actual devil
thought he was talking nonsense anyhow
as they get closer to the house he
starts to realize something's wrong
since back on the tram power told him
that she couldn't get close to the bad
devil because if she did then it would
use meowy's a shield therefore the fact
that she's walking this close to the
house directly contradicts what she said
leading denji to finally understand that
all of it was a lie as the two of them
then quickly draw their weapons this
Split Second was The crucial moment
because if he was able to land a hit
then he'd be able to just run away and
tell makima but if power landed the hit
then denji would get fed to the bat
devil sadly for Amy misses by an inch
and after getting knocked down by the
blood Hammer she drags his body into the
abandoned house one thing I love about
the bat devil here is that he's
basically a connoisseur of human blood
and that he knows which kind tastes best
and you know from this episode we
learned that the blood of children is
great the blood of pregnant women is
even better but the blood of other
Devils pretty much tastes like raw
sewage that's why when he drinks denji
he almost chokes because of how
disgusting it is since denji being a
devil hybrid means his blood tastes like
crap despite him looking like a human
still though it was enough to regenerate
the bat Devil's missing arm bringing him
back to full and complete strength with
his full power he no longer had to keep
hiding in this abandoned house and his
first order of business was to watch the
taste of denji's Tainted blood out of
his mouth by eating some of the children
in the nearby town before that happens
though power understandably wants meowy
back because the whole reason she
betrayed denji in the first place was
based on the promise that her cat would
be returned however one thing we need to
know about this universe is that a
binding contract can only be made
between a human and a devil meaning that
when power made this agreement with the
bat there was nothing actually holding
him to his side of the deal this
explains how he had the free will to
completely ignore their agreement and he
swallows me how we Haul as punishment
for having to drink that tainted blood
immediately after that he eats power as
well before flying off and this is the
moment where denji kind of turned into a
typical Shonen protagonist at least for
a few seconds usually in most Shonen
anime like this the MC never gives up
because he has some kind of noble goal
that he's like striving towards but in
denji's case although his goal isn't
really that Noble he's at least in this
episode not giving up despite being
betrayed and nearly killed his goal of
touching melons is still more important
to him than anything and so he's willing
to keep going even when he's already
been beaten down to be fair there is
also the element that denji knows how it
feels to lose a pad because at first he
thought pashita was dead and as the
other time when he lost Vegeta before
finding him again so yeah he knows what
it feels like and so in that sense he's
able to empathize with power about what
happened to meowie that being said he
still makes it super clear that his
primary motivation here is boobs in that
way you could say that Aki was wrong
when he said that denji has no
motivation or conviction because here we
can see he's painfully tearing apart his
own face just for the chance to grab
some melons to denji his goal is as
serious to him as anyone else's and so
he's willing to get hurt if it means he
can rip the bat Devil's stomach open and
get to touch power's chest what follows
this is a compelling fight between
chainsaw man and the bat devil and for
me this was epic from start to finish
the choreography made this significantly
more engaging than the manga which is
what you want an anime to do and they
got it right when conveying just how
unhinged and crazy dingy is as a person
one of my favorite Parts in terms of
Animation was when denji was struggling
to stand up when the bat devil blasted
him with the sonar Cannon and in case
you're wondering I'm 99 sure this
ability is inspired by bats using their
voices for echolocation the way
everything shatters when denji crashes
into it was great but it also helps to
show us just how durable his tiny human
body has become the fact he can survive
an attack like this and hold up a car
with his bare hands it's a level of
super strength that wasn't that apparent
in the first two episodes also while
we're on the topic of him holding the
car it was in this moment the denji
immediately lost any claim he might have
had to being a typical Shonen
protagonist because even though he knew
a guy was inside he still threw the
whole thing as a projectile weapon when
you compare this action to how we saved
a girl's life moments earlier it's hard
to tell whether he's interested in being
the hero type or not on the one hand if
he truly didn't care about civilians
then he wouldn't have bothered trying to
help this girl but on the other hand he
clearly didn't care about this random
guy's life my thinking is that the
difference between these two actions is
purely due to denji's insane horniness
because if we imagine for a second that
a woman was in this car instead I don't
actually think he would have thrown it
his language here also blatantly
suggests that he just prefer saving
women over men and no mega spoilers but
chapter 103 if you read the whole of
that it just basically kind of confirms
that yeah he is doing this for the
ladies like that's why he's doing it
anyway this episode comes to an end with
denji tearing apart the bat devil once
and for all and what was funny about
this is that this huge devil begs him to
stay away from him just like how the
zombie devil did in episode 1. overall
I'd give this episode the first 10 out
of 10 of the season I mean the animation
was Flawless the the voice acting for
the bat devil was perfect so honestly
there isn't anything here to stop it
being a perfect tan that being said
though this is just my opinion at the
end of the day so let me know in the
comments down below how you rated the
episode and be sure to check out my
previous reviews if you're new to the
channel until the next one peace out